Mike my hearty hear the game spot news
update so if you're looking for a little
more bang for your buck it might be
worth picking up a steam machine at
least according to valve CEO Gabe Newell
in an interview with develop Gabe Newell
said at console price points we're going
to have machines like alien wares which
are faster than today's consoles he went
on to say that with the steam machine
you'll get better performance and that
it's connected to everything you like
about the PC and internet to begin with
on valve's steam machine store page 13
separate hardware units are listed with
alienware system priced at four hundred
fifty dollars the final specs are not
explicitly stated but the most recent
steam machine specs assessment suggested
the device carried an intel core i3
dual-core processor and NVIDIA GeForce
GTX with two gigs of gddr5 memory four
gigs of ddr3 l system ram and a 500
gigabyte hard drive whether that means
alien where's entry level system carries
a meaningful computational advantage or
disadvantage over the ps4 and Xbox one
is still a matter for debate in the US
the ps4 and Xbox one typically retail at
one hundred dollars less than alienware
steam box elsewhere in the interview
Newell claimed that valves steam machine
enterprise will break down the long-held
belief that pc gaming doesn't fit in
living room spaces so what do you think
does this steam machine had a leg up
over consoles considering you can get
the xbox one or ps4 for about three
hundred fifty dollars I think new old
pricing might be a bit off but anyway
for more news stay tuned at Gamescom
you